quelle lecture faire des résultats du
scrutin à quoi ressemble le nouveau
parlement européen quelques-unes des
questions abordées lors de cette
conférence à la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques de l'ue vs qu expert
de lieux et journalistes spécialisés ont
dressé les prochaines échéances
européennes les élections désormais
passer de nouveaux enjeux se pose
désormais constitution des groupes de
l'hémicycle ou encore élection du
président du parlement
pour nous c'est une législature qui
commence au parlement européen donc on
est qu'au tout début
deux de ces grands enjeux pour peut-être
pour le citoyen qui a voté jeudi bon ben
maintenant mon vote est passée s'est
terminée il ya un parlement il ya des
élus non ça ne fait que commencer pour
ces élus vont devoir travailler ensemble
vont devoir constituer des familles des
groupes politiques
dans la salle une vingtaine de personnes
venues s'informer sur le nouveau
parlement européen
beaucoup de questions ont porté sur
l'écologie les cas du bric cité de
l'italie ont également été abordés le
cas italien
donc du coup j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses sur le cas italien l'évolution à
des parties évolution dans les sondages
et par rapport aux dernières élections à
dupuy depuis 2012 de la ligue à de
l'émotion des électeurs qui ont changé
de camp etc
c'est très intéressant côte d'ivoire au
niveau social devant au niveau politique
a très intéressant on a débriefé quelque
sorte avec différents angles l'actualité
toute récente des élections
et ça permet de mieux se préparer à
analyser les événements qui vont suivre
prochaine échéance pour le parlement
européen la session inaugurale les 751
nouveaux eurodéputés se réuniront à
partir du 2 juillet à strasbourg il y
éliront leur nouveau président